ce soir je voudrais je crains pas la
dynamique est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
pour eux n'est pas d'anniversaire mon
chéri d'amour
merci on t'aime fort mon chéri j'ai tout
misé portes du plateau est bon thème
rené était pour souvenir de cette élite
au palatin mois et demi tarif d'un amour
ma chérie côté de moi et je connais on a
lu rené et je viens bientôt à marseille
et jean va fêter ça tous les deux je
t'appelle ah ouais c'est impossible
attention je vais venir à marseille pour
te voir aussi je te fais un énorme bisou
morlaix t'embrasse ta famille tu
embrasses la femme qui est un ami à tout
le monde ce soir là j'espère qu'il va
gagner un match en ligue des champions
j'avoue que ça me dit si bien joué ça
débat
[Applaudissements]